Speaker 1: So we're going to start today with
this incredible interview that took place
with the now acquitted Kyle Rittenhouse on
the Fox News Channel's Tucker Carlson program,
this was a much promoted interview and it
confirms every single one of our suspicions
about how Kyle Rittenhouse would be treated
after his acquittal, which is they're making
a hero out of him, or at least they're trying
to.
And as you watch these clips, consider the
types of issues on which this 18 year old
kid who killed two people when he was 17 is
being not only asked to weigh in, but Tucker's
reactions.
Are full grown men reacting as if this is
who we should be asking about such issues
as the FBI, prosecutorial misconduct, self-defense
and on and on and on.
So this is not only the exact, predictable
attempt to make a hero out of Kyle Rittenhouse
that we predicted, but it is actually making
him to be even more than that.
It's making him an authority on self-defense.
It's making him so many more things.
So let's just jump right into it.
Tucker Carlson introducing this and saying
This is the type of person.
You want more of in your country, if you can
imagine that
Speaker 2: during the course of our long conversation,
current now struck us as bright, decent, sincere,
dutiful and hardworking.
Exactly the kind of person you'd want many
more of in your country.
He's not especially political.
He never wanted to be the symbol of anything.
Speaker 1: So even just starting this with
this is just a great guy.
I'm Tucker and you trust me, and I tell you
all the time what we need in this country
and we need more.
Kyle Rittenhouse's.
That's how they set the stage.
And then immediately, you have Kyle Rittenhouse
saying this was about self-defense.
This trial was about self-defense.
Big Picture, which the right loves.
He's their hero.
Speaker 3: It wasn't Kyle Rittenhouse on trial
in Wisconsin.
It was the right to self-defense under right.
And if I was convicted, no one would be able
no one would ever be privileged to defend
their life against attackers.
Speaker 1: Now what Kyle Rittenhouse wants
you to believe and what others want you to
believe is that if in this particular case,
there had been a conviction.
And again, it could have been a conviction
just on one of the counts, it could have been
well with the Rosenbaum killing.
It wasn't self-defense, but maybe with Anthony
Huber, it was which my instinct was.
If there was going to be any guilty verdict,
it would have been Rittenhouse and I would
have been Rosenbaum and not Huber.
But that's neither here nor there.
He wants you to believe any any guilty verdict
here would mean people can't defend themselves
anymore.
However, that's an extremely myopic view of
the facts, which include his choice to go
there and his choice to go to provide medical
help, supposedly, but with a gun and on and
on.
This is not about adjudicating the trial,
but it's the idea that what does this 18 year
old know about self-defense?
He got himself into an insane situation, got
away with killing two people under the guise
of self-defense.
But now we're going to him for advice about
self-defense and what this means.
It's crazy, of course.
At a certain point, you've got to bring up
God, and he believes he had God on his side.
You know,
Speaker 2: you just got acquitted.
Yeah, I mean, like two days ago.
So that was the first thing I noticed that
you seem very calm.
You don't seem like someone who's just been
through, you know, had his mind blown.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
And then inside, I'm freaking out.
But the best thing you do?
You freak out.
Everybody else freaks out.
It's like a chain reaction.
Yes.
So the best thing I can do is stay calm.
Speaker 2: Do you feel like you've been watched
over?
Speaker 3: Believe God's been on my side for
the beginning?
Yeah.
Speaker 1: There you go.
I mean, what?
What?
What an amazing perspective that Tucker is
eliciting here, right?
And the entire interview was essentially like
this.
And if you what's very interesting is.
It really illuminates the difference between
a propaganda interview and a real interview,
because now we're going to look at an example
of when Rittenhouse is allowed to get away
with something with Tucker that he never would
have been able to get away with in court.
He says, You know, after I did shoot Joseph
Rosenbaum, I was going to render first aid
when in the trial.
Through cross-examination, it was clear that
that that was not the case.
Speaker 2: He shot, you decide at that point
in awesomeness remembering you want to go
turn yourself in to the police.
Speaker 3: Yes.
After I shoot Mr. Rosenbaum, he tried to grab
my gun.
I was running away.
There's a gunshot behind me.
After I shoot him, I run around the car because
I was going to go render first aid to him.
Speaker 1: Even this, I mean this this story
is not the story that came out in the trial.
Rosenbaum grabbed my gun.
In order to take it from Kyle Rittenhouse,
that's a detail that was left unclear from
the case.
I'm not saying was or wasn't self-defense
again.
As I said from the beginning, I think the
facts lend themselves to a reasonable doubt
that this was self-defense, as Kyle Rittenhouse
saw it.
But this story, he tried to grab my gun and
I still ran around the car to try to give
him first aid after the first shot.
That's not really what the video appears to
show, but in a propaganda interview, you're
allowed to get away with it.
Speaker 3: I wasn't able to, because then
there is a mob forming and calling for my
execution to get him and kill him.
Speaker 1: And of course, what's in between
that that Kyle Rittenhouse doesn't mention
are the three further shots to Rosenbaum after
Rosenbaum was already seemingly disabled.
So it's not about relitigating the case.
It's about understanding that this is a propaganda
interview where he's allowed to give any version
of events, even versions of events not backed
up by the exhibits presented in the trial.
And that conflict with with what came out
in the trial.
OK, let's look at another clip here.
Speaker 3: This case has nothing to do with
race.
It never had anything to do with race.
It had to do with the right to self-defense.
Right.
I'm not a racist person.
I support the BLM movement.
I support peacefully demonstrating, and I
believe there needs to be change.
I believe there's a lot of prosecutorial misconduct,
not just in my case, but in other cases.
And it's just amazing to see how how much
a prosecutor can take advantage of somebody.
Speaker 1: So once again, this is another
one of those examples of 18 year old Kyle
Rittenhouse on prosecutorial misconduct there,
making him an authority there, making him
a hero there, making him a poster child when
just because you were accused of a crime doesn't
mean you know anything about supposed prosecutorial
misconduct.
And he knows that now.
And people are commenting, Oh, he supports
BLM.
OK, maybe we have no idea what that means.
Maybe he does.
I'm not denying that he does.
It might just mean he supports BLM insofar
as they have a right to be heard at protests.
It could mean it doesn't really matter here,
but he's learning the talking points.
And in this next clip, you're going to see
him do the FBI stuff, which is remember among
the right now you have to criticize the FBI.
And he says, I don't know if they're going
to be able to keep me safe.
You know how the FBI works, which it with
this, this is classic red meat to those who
know what to listen for.
All right,
Speaker 3: to look at the facts of what happened.
Do you do you feel the threats?
I do.
I see some of the threats.
Some of the things people say.
It's absolutely sickening.
Speaker 2: Has are you confident that the
government will protect you from these threats?
Because that's of course, the government's
job?
Speaker 3: I hope so, but we all know how
the FBI works.
Yeah.
Speaker 2: I mean, looking back, it's been
all you know.
OK.
Speaker 1: So he's on, but he knows the talking
points.
He knows it.
We've got to be very skeptical and critical
of the FBI.
That's something that grew significantly under
Trump, and that has become sort of a standard
calling card now of right wing media.
So he's he's got that one.
He learned that one, for sure.
The topic of Joe Biden came up and Kyle Rittenhouse,
even given the opportunity to send a message
directly to President Joe Biden,
Speaker 3: say, it's like my case.
Speaker 2: What did you make of the United
States calling you a white supremacist?
Speaker 3: Mr. President, if I could say one
thing to you, I would urge you to go back
and watch the trial and understand the facts
before you make a statement.
Speaker 2: That's not a small thing to be
called that.
Speaker 3: No, it's it's actual malice.
Defaming my character for him to say something
like that.
Speaker 1: Mm-Hmm.
Defaming defamation.
We're going to come back to that because that
actually comes up again now in the midst of
this.
You might remember that all sorts of shady
characters got wrapped up with Kyle Rittenhouse
early on.
One of them is Lin Wood.
This sort of Trump affiliated, wacky attorney
who's made all sorts of insane claims about
COVID, as well as about the 2020 elections.
And this is this is sort of a departure from
what we've been talking about.
He.
Kyle Rittenhouse talks about how he believes
he was taken advantage of by some of these
lawyers who were raising money for themselves,
and he was kept in jail.
And it's actually this is this is just a crazy
aspect to this.
Speaker 3: How long were you there?
I was in jail for eighty seven days and this
goes as follows.
Then with Lin Wood, who Lin Wood was raising
money on my behalf and he held me in jail
for eighty seven days, disrespected my wishes.
Put me on who media interviews, which I should
never have done when she said, Oh, you're
going to go talk to The Washington Post, which
was not a good idea, along with John Pierce.
They said I was safer in jail instead of at
home with my family.
And then after I'm bill, your lawyer said
that my lawyer said that John Pierson, Lin
Wood.
Speaker 2: Eighty seven days is a long time
to be in jail.
Speaker 3: It was.
It was very long.
I lost a lot of weight in there.
I said, Send gained it back.
Speaker 2: I know the feeling.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: So this is crazy.
This is a propaganda interview, but it also
shows you that these sort of predatory figures
like Lin Wood, they're everywhere and there's
no opportunity that they won't take advantage
of.
And here Rittenhouse talks about how he was
treated in jail.
Now there's two.
There's two sides to this part.
Let's listen.
Speaker 3: But but I didn't have running water
seriously.
I had a phone also, but I did not have running
water, so I didn't shower until November 20th.
How long?
October 30, 1st to November 20th.
I did not take a shower.
That's disgusting.
Very.
I smelt terrible.
I felt sick.
I lost a weight.
My health was degrading.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So what's interesting about this one is this
has happened in the context of the Jan. six
riots as well, where you know, we by we I
mean, we on the left have been sounding the
alarm about jail and prison conditions, pretrial
detention, et cetera, for more than a decade
on this program.
And the right has not cared about it until.
It affects them.
And so now you've heard everybody from Marjorie
Taylor Greene to who knows who on the right
complain about the alleged conditions, conditions
in which the alleged Jan. six Trump rioters
have been held and now jail conditions all
of a sudden are a big deal to them.
And similarly, now all of a sudden, with the
Rittenhouse stuff that issue is now they care
about that issue.
Now it's actually an important issue.
But it's, again, the brazen nature by which
they only care about it when it affects them.
There have been questions is Kyle Rittenhouse
going to sue media outlets for things they
said about him, various legal opinions about
whether that would go anywhere?
But Kyle Rittenhouse sort of using coded language
to say, Yeah, we may do that
Speaker 2: and they would like to see you,
you know, help make this better by holding
some of these liars to account.
Do you plan to do that?
Speaker 3: I have really good lawyers who
are taking care of that right now.
So I'm hoping one day there will be some.
There will be accountability for their actions
that they did.
Speaker 2: OK, so you're you're intent on
not you're not going to let that go.
Speaker 3: Like I said,
Speaker 1: so suggesting there that there
may well be defamation suits coming and where
those will go.
We have absolutely no idea, but it's looking
like there's going to be a very litigious
year or two for Kyle Rittenhouse.
And then lastly, Kyle Rittenhouse, the lion
is Asian, and the heroism continues with Kyle
talking about what kind of a career he wants
to pursue.
Speaker 2: What do you think your wife's going
to be like after this?
Speaker 3: I'm hoping I can live a quiet,
stress free life and not and be free of any
intimidation.
Her are harassment and just go on with my
life as a normal 18 year old kid attending
college.
So you're going to go to college?
I am in college.
I'm a student at Arizona State University
now
Speaker 1: in the trial.
It seems like that was not true unless something
is changed, but that's really neither here
nor there.
Speaker 2: What I mean, are you going to go
to campus?
Speaker 3: And I think I am.
I want to.
It's a lot of things we have to look into.
So I don't know for sure yet, but I do intend
on going in campus and pursuing a career in
nursing.
I may change it.
I've been looking at the law.
I may want to become a lawyer.
I haven't completely decided yet, but I've
been looking.
I want to be a nurse, so I've been doing the
prerequisites for
Speaker 1: how nice, right?
So exactly as predicted, this is the new hero.
This is the new hero.
And of course, you can judge for yourselves
based on your values and how you see the world,
whether you think that he's worthy of being
designated this hero, but weighing in on everything
from prosecutorial misconduct to the trustworthiness
of the FBI on the basis of the fact that he
killed two people and was acquitted for it,
exactly as we predicted on December 14th,
we will be doing our next David Pakman Show
Viewer Town Hall.
It will be on the Pacman Live at YouTube channel.
Make sure you subscribe to that channel at
youtube.com slash Pacman Live.
We're going to take a quick break and be back
right after this.